and today I'm gonna tell you more about
how you can of tomato your github
workflow with robots github have a one
of the best API I think one of the best
out there so there are the things like
github applications you can name some of
them like greenkeeper century Zen hub
Travis CI Cutco style CI whatever
whatever whatever there's a lot of them
you can check them out on github.com
slash marketplace what is important is
that github applications are first-class
actors within github that means that
they can do almost anything that regular
users do which means that they can
command under issues open you PRS change
files crate commits and so on and what
is important is that they work with
general permission and building web
hooks however it's too complicated but
elating in receiving web hooks might be
an overkill if you want for example
build a simple application that will
greet you
your new contributors your repository
and people from github understood this
problem and they want to simplify the
process of creating new robots so they
build a nice framework with such a nice
logo and you can check it out on provid
github today oh so the name is prabhav
and what is proper properties a
framework for creating robots with no
chairs and it takes care of receiving
and validating web hooks so actually it
takes out of the scene of all of this
complicating logic and let you
concentrate on building something that
you have in your mind so actually it
opens an ability to scrub github like
you can watch for changes receive some
meta information Eliza and trigonal
action and response how it works
actually Probot is Express application
under the hood that deals with
have API so let's take a look how on a
simple example of super tiny gentle bot
that will greet everyone who opens the
new issues ask if all new robot you can
do this with MPX create Probot app
exactly like you do was create react app
if you are react developer and an index
JS file you should expert a function
that takes robot as a parameter so in
this function you can put all of this
logic now you want to build so for
example we are subscribing for opening
every issue and then pass a handler this
handler is a synchronous and it takes
the contacts can text contains some meta
information about event that just
happens so we check if we retrieve body
from issue and then we check if body
includes things we answer you're welcome
otherwise we answer things then we
create new command in this context of
this issue and publish it with contacts
that github that issue create command
and people actually use robots they
automate them their daily work and save
them a lot of time for example the most
popular one is a robot's tail the
sailboat closes issue after some period
of an activity like no one commands
under this issue it's not relevant
anymore so we close it another example
is welcome but that greet every new
contributor to your repository like if a
user open an issue of request for the
first time to your application this bot
would greet them also if their pull
request will be merged this bot will
publish a go congratulations to this new
contributor
another example is settings bot
this boat allows you to keep your
repertory setting inside of your repo
inside the settings Yama file in a
github folder and this open is an
ability to for your contributors to make
a pull request to the settings of your
repository and even more actually you
can move issues between different
repositories how to label them get reach
the I report lock threads require
updating dogs a sink Forks between
torque and upstream and more can check
out more awesome boss on provid github
IL / apps and what I wanted to do with
this talk is to encourage you to try
this framework to build your own BOTS
like this is an amazing idea give it a
chance try it this could save you a ton
of your time this can automatically
handle your routine tasks so I hope
after this talk we will see more useful
Pro BOTS and some of them are gonna
build by you thank you
[Applause]